v3 krimiplot bahro 3 nachdem da wir sind
drauf okay ich bin drauf kommt kraft
getreten wir sind ja leider drauf ja ich
weiß gar nicht dürfen wir über die tode
reden ich schon passiert sind lieber
nicht mehr weil die folge wurde das
kommt ja denn ich früher okay es sind
leute gestorben so wie kann man sagen
dass ich da mal nicht mehr und freunde
da ich das letztlich doch das jetzt mal
direkt am anfang auch halo war klar was
wir schauen hier noch schön weiter hier
sind sogar auch noch ist aber nicht so
gutes drin
du warst hier wie sie die fackeln und
richtig weil ich nicht gefackelt habe
ich habe mir einfach nicht fragt nicht
lange gefackelt der bürger an die
schlucht und du wolltest was erzählt
naja ich muss etwas sehr wichtiges
erzählen und zwar geht es um danke dass
du es mit nimmst und zwar geht es um
hast du einmal eigentlich mag ich hab
das ganze alben legal ist
es geht um eine sache die wir hier slava
hier können uns lover mitnehmen
nationale hast du 1 1
der heimatforscher was und immer nur
eisen und keine diamanten es geht um
eine sache die wir die ich sagen wollte
bzw
[Musik]
muss sage ich jetzt mal ja gesagt weil
monat um etwa die hälfte also als ob
kommen zu mir
alter ist vergiftet mann und china so
viel um die höhe
das zieht dich auf ein halbes herz
runter nach ich sterbe hre nicht hierher
also wir müssen aufpassen
jetzt gibt es spiel kannst du ein
feuerzeug machen glaube zu wissen
dies gilt war das motto aus den zwei
diamanten die haben dann schwer ich weiß
heute die ammann schweiz jetzt nicht
viel besser als ein eisen schwer
allerdings benötige ich das darf jetzt
mal an kalorien macht das okay ich
benötige das für eine bestimmte aktion
die ihr morgen sehen werdet und zwar
werde ich heute schon gegen ende der
folge weglaufen von hallodri ich werde
mich in die mitte weil ich mit mich mit
dem treffen werde
mit mci expert.de und ich werde gegen
ihn kämpfen in der mitte das haben wir
deswegen festgehalten nicht weil ich
sage ja ich bin sooo geil ich habe schon
so viele geile sachen ich muss unbedingt
gegen irgendwen kämpfen sondern es geht
einfach darum dass dort nicht so klug
dass ich jetzt heruntergesprungen
sondern es geht ganz easy darum dass ich
in den urlaub fahre und ich bin in die
schlucht hier unten gesprungen die st
ich dachte hier werden coole sachen ich
komm zu dem ok springen ich weiß ich es
gibt also ich war im urlaub und man
dazusagen nur videos für danke
man darf nur videos für ein paar tage
vor produzieren für drei tage das wisst
ihr ja alle weil ihr auch das regelwerk
mehr oder weniger kennt und ihr seid
einfach die ganzen und schaffen im alter
richtig eng aus weil das wissen ja denke
ich schon und deswegen wird das
natürlich auch sonst wenn ich dann in
zwei wochen vor produzieren würde wird
es total die spannung raus nehmen
deswegen hab ich gesagt ich möchte nicht
nicht einfach sagen okay ich beende war
sondern ich möchte mit einem kampf gehen
auch wenn ich dir vielleicht verlieren
werde was sehr sehr wahrscheinlich ist
sie könnte mal wetten abschließt in den
kommentaren
100 euro wenn ihr jetzt kritik als
gewinnen wenn ich gewinne
10 milliarden millionen mal das thema ja
aber naja ich hab dann auf jeden fall in
der gruppe d fraktion will mit sich mit
mir treffen da meinte timm soja könig
machen komme ich gerne hin so und jetzt
treffe ich mich mit irgendwelchen
koordinaten die er mir die weiß ich noch
gar nicht das ist total dumm weil du
vollidiot er du weißt ja jetzt gar nicht
wo du hin laufen ja ich gehe erst mal
einfach in die oberflächen in der
nächsten folge werde ich dann mit dem
darf ich nicht reden weil einem anderen
team ist aber dann wäre ich da halt hin
laufen und dann werde ich gegen tim
kämpfe der nächsten folge am hast du
noch platz im inventar oder kannst du
mal darüber bauen
du willst immer abgehängt und ja das
werde ich auf jeden fall in der nächsten
folge machen das wollte ich nur
ankündigen dass ich in der nächsten
folge wahrscheinlich auch wenn ich den
kampf dann gewinne gegen tim werde ich
trotzdem gehen weil ich nenne diese
produzieren kann
ich denke allerdings nicht dass ich
gewinnen werde allerdings können wir
schon auf morgen freuen das dauert ein
kampf kommt hallodri wird daran nicht
teilnehmen
die wird auch nicht an teilnehmen weil
ich gesagt habe ich möchte dagegen einen
anderen kämpfen deswegen wird stege sich
das ganze anschauen quasi mehr oder
weniger v3 cripper da hinten
als scheiß krack man sich an höhe sind
wir wenn ich euch nicht leiden können
alles sagen wir sind auf 414 hier
müssten die könnten diamanten am bienen
sein wie ich dachte gerade hier sind
welche aber es neue dieses lapislazuli
klappt es ja ok das wollte ich einfach
noch ansprechen das war's jetzt quasi
[Musik]
vielleicht vielleicht sind da hinter
ihnen wir haben das könnte ja auch sein
ja deswegen werde ich jetzt gleich uhr
zeigt auch schon wieder fünf minuten
wenn die uhr zehn minuten anzeigt werde
ich mich dann nach oben bauen also hoch
laufen und dann schauen ob ich ja ja
genau an die asfinag in alles dass dazu
die frage ist wo sie diamanten da ich
nicht vor
m hast du noch dieses buch dann kann ich
mich schon mal rasen zaubern
da doch ich will jetzt diamanten finden
ja ich mich auch den diamanten
aber wir brauchen noch einen amboss
deswegen dann sagen du brauchst du
irgendwelche brauchst du nicht auch hier
sind verzauberung tisch und so kann ich
wenn ich schon ein buch habe es so da
muss nur mit dem amboss zusammen passt
leider dann hast du noch offen
er werte die aus warum habe ich schon
wieder eine sonnenblume dabei ganz
ehrlich ok kommentar gelesen warum hat
der alu ja die sonnenblume dabei ich
habe so eine sonnenblume mit haben sie
nicht gesehen ich fand ja ich berate
mich jetzt halt mal eben ganz leisen
weil man für sondern was natürlich auch
nicht gleisen benötigt ich werde dir
danach dann ich werde hallodri danach
dann quasi einen chip geben sagt das
habe ich nicht brauche also restliches
eisen et cetera richtiger could gas wird
licht angemacht hat
[Musik]
so deswegen lege ich jetzt hier nicht
einfach irgendwo so ein kack diamant sei
es ganz egal ob erich findeisen gold den
ganzen rummel dabei als lucile
du sparst gut ich gebe mir noch ein
bisschen lager für den kampf also
wirklich keine großen hoffnungen weil ja
ich denke nicht dass ich gegen tim so
eine krasse chance habe ein wegen tim
weil wegen thema hast kannst du das buch
ball geben kommt zu dir geschwind nun
ein malbuch das superphone sie und wenn
ihr dann quasi danach weiter schauen
wollt und denkt euch joh das ist gerade
voll da ist die hülle dort wo die sind
hallodri nimmt ja auch mit auf mein gott
und dann könnte ich da gerne
vorbeischauen
was brauche ich denn für diesen richtige
braterei ich hab ja ich habe mal anders
[Musik]
das wasser relativ wenig kohle so klopp
hereinspaziert guck mal ich die klimpel
ja geil nochmal werden so ist jetzt
richtig viel eisen nicht korrekt ist das
alles wir haben wir nahezu nie 'ne kiste
eigentlich habe ich werfe mir schon ein
paar sachen zu und dann werde ich nicht
nach oben begeben
hast du noch pfeile ich hab einen teil
der bridgestone achilles spaß die mama
auf den shooter fans erstmal zucker erde
laub zu stoppen lassen das gibt mir das
ganze oder zurückgelassen euro die manz
schwarzpulver richtige idee vielleicht
nicht die mit einem die idee hingehen
wie macht man könnte ich habe eins aber
nur einen solch ein rennen als ich dich
mach mal eine kiste hier noch für dich
mach ich hätte mal den rest zahlen
wollte eigentlich der mann ja du hast ja
noch ein bisschen zeit die zu gebieten
lebten länger sehen ist wird schon
nichts erleidet zurechtkommt ich weiß
nicht wie man da der hohe zwar das heißt
so oft gelesen und twittern herrlich
die man mir so ein spinnennetz ich
schaue immer nach wiederum haben die
abbauen mit einer schere oder irgendwo
im netz
mein kraft so dass luisi ist geht gar
nicht reden oder was gegen die mein gott
ist das scheißegal
wir sollten langsam nach oben marschiert
zogen mussten ja ich nehme ich eben die
ganzen sachen die ich brauche ich packe
da noch fressen hin wenn ich hier auch
mit nach oben ich muss ja dann weglaufen
ach so ja es stimmt die trasse dann hast
du noch pfeile für mich nein habe ich
schon groß so dass manchmal abchecken
also ich bin dabei
ok du bist in polen ich kann ja oder ja
jetzt werden auch fünf minuten
aufnahmezeit in der zeit muss jetzt nach
oben laufen dann ich bin auch dabei was
ist denn mit den ganzen sachen in der
kiste jetzt steht welche kiste ein paar
sachen kann ich hier nur halt noch
mitnehmen
die wichtigen golden lassen glaubt man
im märz also warte ich nehme ich habe
jetzt den rest kann mir da drin lassen
den amboss nämlich noch mit let's go
okay okay
so erhielt jetzt hier lang den fluss
nach oben
bremen einfach schwer das bitte nicht
wieder nach oben graben wenn ich dass
wir wieder in seinem werk nicht
ja damit ihr hof hier war darüber so an
der seite wo welche seite ein wasserfall
in der schlucht bin ich nach in der
schluck wieder schwimmen schwimmen im
rhein
ich weiß gar nicht wo ich hier nochmal
gehen kann jetzt auch keine steine dabei
doch habe ich auf steine
wir müssen echt ein bisschen durch durch
widor würde ich jetzt behaupten ein
bisschen was ein bisschen beeilen damit
wir langsam nach oben kommen vermutlich
ja ja wir sind schon auf 0 32 also
bezuele soll wir hier über also wenn du
hunger hast dann bauen wir es nochmal
bin ja soo eigentlich wäre sein
minecraft profil deswegen kann ich
brücken sehr sehr gut bauen die man
sehen kann bisher stark in brücken bauen
und brückenbauer scheiße geht wieder
nach unten
der wetterdienst ja ja das war ja das
kannst du gerade übernehmen das bringt
nichts dann wieder freie zusammen haben
eine gute note 3 philipp pohl rom
ja das ist jetzt echt das problem ich
weiß nicht genau wo tim ist aber wir
haben jetzt noch zwei euro lasse sich
vielleicht jetzt sehr sehr dumm
scheiße alter bräuche langen diesem
scheiß bürokraft zu bauen hat sich mal
an ich habe man am plan ich verabschiede
mich schon mal von der hallodri andere
seite hoch damit eventuell auch etwas
bin dadurch geschwommen einfach überlegt
man das ja ja ja hallo ok krass ich
jetzt ja ich bin auf dem weg als ob er
einfach hoch schwimmt ja ich bin halt
ein riesch ich habe deswegen hab ich mir
gedacht sie könnten nur durch morris
noch fahren ist ein motto oder richtig
da hab ich dir recht nicht abbauen
konnte ok ja ich komme dass die aufnahme
ist bei 14 minuten dann ist es ja
perfekt
ach so du bist aber dennoch an der höhle
oder wie ich bin einfach durchgeschoben
durch das so stimmt das ist noch ganz
sehr dunkel hier irgendwie unter wasser
[Musik]
schaffen aber nicht mal schon ein
bisschen schade weil du willst du
natürlich ist es wieder nachts klar an
den song aufnehmen tonnen und komme ich
ja dann bin ich jetzt oben ich noch ein
bisschen weiter sind ist doch scheißegal
ich wollte dann aber ich wollte mich
aber doch von ihr verabschieden die hat
auch so nicht durch die wüste
durchgelaufen oder wie rodrigo bist du
du bist du hin gelaufen ich stehe auch
hier außen also da wo du quasi
hochgekommen ist warte ja ich werde mir
okay ja ich will auch den namen einmal
das geschlecht gesagten hin
aber ich kann sowieso nichts zu nehmen
ich bin voll scheiße natürlich damit
machen sonst egal so ja okay wir dürfen
jetzt nicht aus nämlich so ok kann diese
sind freunde das war die letzte folge
von uns zusammen als diese noch nach
oben gekommen ich werde mich in der
nächsten folge morgen mit themen treffen
und dann jetzt gepumpt weggehauen mal
die seite wartet jemand mit dir ja ich
fand es auch sehr gern eine wundervolle
zeit schade das ist jetzt echt halt nur
so kurz war habe ich hätte ehrlich
gedacht die stärke in der ersten zweiten
oder dritten folge aber nicht dass wir
so weit kommen freunde woche ist ja kaum
uns bitte nicht helfen wenn ich weiter
schauen wollt könnt ihr heute schon
jetzt ohne dann beschreiben wie immer
verlinkt und dann sehen wir uns wann
anders wieder morgen